it is said that Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell has one of the toughest
jobs in politics why well he's taken
fire from both the left and the populace
right sometimes including yours truly on
a daily basis
earlier this evening believe it or not I
sat down with him and he was nice enough
to give an exclusive interview to the
Ingram angle where he addresses a range
of topics the wave of sex harassment
revelations rocking Capitol Hill the
Alabama Senate race and a lot more but
we began with the gops do-or-die tax
reform push senator mcconnell thanks so
much for joining us tonight so you just
left the Senate floor the battle is
underway for tax reform how's it looking
unanimous Republican vote to go forward
with the tax bill hope it'll be
unanimous at the end but we all agreed
to get started after a lot of
negotiations I'm optimistic we're going
to deliver a comprehensive tax reform to
the American people for the first time
in 31 years now Marco Rubio and Mike Lee
kind of a last-minute move are pushing
for a hike in the corporate tax cut from
20 percent to 22 and they then want to
give more relief to lower income people
with children where is that gonna go and
well what is that is that gonna be a
monkey wrench and your plan here let's
see I mean there it's open for amendment
there will be plenty of amendments both
on the Republican side and the
Democratic side but what I think we have
100% agreement on Laura is that we want
to do comprehensive tax reforms for the
first time since the second Reagan
administration
you know the doubts may twist a little
bit as we go along but the core is
middle-class tax relief and making our
businesses more competitive against
other businesses around the world and to
keep our jobs here in this country so
Donald Trump originally wanted 15% went
up to 20% and you're saying tonight it
could go up to 22% yeah this is a
preferences 20 but the Senate's gonna
work its will and there gonna be plenty
of amendments on both sides
but I think the core effort here
middle-class tax relief and keeping our
jobs in the country are going to be
intact at the end some of the headlines
about what you're trying to do with tax
reform
just a couple gops ugly secret tax plan
would force a quarter trillion dollar
cut in Medicare 1.4 trillion to the
deficit is gonna really hurt higher
education I'm gonna make it more
expensive college presidents say
specifically on this quarter trillion
dollar cut overtime and Medicare so it's
going to force spending cuts on Medicare
that's of course completely false how
it's just not it's not true we're not
touching Medicare at all in this in this
bill not at all and on the deficit
question you raised we'd only have to
grow four tenths of one percent over the
next ten years
four tenths of one percent over the next
ten years to fill that one point
trillion dollar gap that the critics
keep saying is going to sit there as if
the economy wasn't going to respond to
this incredible relief it's going to get
from the burden of high taxation on set
so you're not worried about the deficit
you think the the growth tax cuts is not
going to be a deficit producing effort
why didn't you guys go with the border
adjustment tax that would have actually
infused some more money into this
process you would have been able to get
cleaner tax reform cleaner tax that's
Ryan was for it some people called it a
value-added tax there was a lot of
resistance to that lot and it was sort
of aired out by the house last year when
we're in the early discussions about
this
I couldn't have passed it in the Senate
we have to deal with what can pass I
need 50 votes we have 52 Republicans we
have all 52 who want to get the yes but
that was just not something I can sell
in the Senate John McCain has been kind
thorn in the side of the Trump
administration they've had you know
acrimonious relationship going back to
the campaign right now do you think he's
the biggest obstacle to this getting to
the ultimate 50/50 he voted to get on
the bill and I know dr. John McCain well
enough to know he's not going to cast a
vote on tax reform over how he may feel
about the current occupant of the White
House you don't think that comes into
play at all I don't think so
let's move on to some other issues
because there's a lot going on in the
country right now on a whole bunch of
fronts the Alabama Senate race has taken
up a lot of oxygen in the political you
know landscape he's up now in the polls
5% you you favored Luther strange but a
lot of money went into supporting Luther
strange he didn't win Roy Moore won I
actually supported mo Brooks but Roy
Moore won and now of course all these
allegations against him you said he
should step aside he may very well win
this election what does that say about
your influence in the Senate your
influences that have any implication for
you
he wants to unseat you he says well
President Trump and I were on the same
side
we both supported Luther strange even
though you supply supported mo Brooks
the people of Alabama decided to go in a
different direction and on December the
12th they'll get to decide who they want
to send to the Senate and we'll deal
with that when that happened so if that
happens there still are senators who say
we could vote to expel him from the US
Senate but what does that say to the
state of Alabama they've heard all the
arguments and I know you said you
believe the women who came forward I
tend to think some of them are credible
as well but people of Alabama are
hearing at all they're gonna make the
decision Alabama and Willow should you
should you and the Senate then
invalidate that by expelling him and
we'll deal with the aftermath of the
decision the people of Alabama make on
December 12 so you think it's a
possibility he could be expelled from
the Senate I think there's a possibility
you will have an ethics issue an ethics
investigation once he gets here yeah I
think it's almost certain you know how
far back with those allegations if they
go back like decades you'll bring up the
committee Wow there's a lot of ethics
investigations going on
fortunately yeah / and that the Senate
doesn't have any sort of fund like the
house has one of those they're calling
it a shush fund or a slush fund to
settle settlements section talking about
harassment Asia yeah well we're taking a
look at completely changing whatever the
status quo is I mean we two weeks ago in
the Senate passed a measure to require
mandatory training we've got a
bipartisan group of Republican and
Democratic women in the Senate given us
advice about the next step and clearly
the status quo is not acceptable
well Kirsten Gillibrand who has been on
this issue when it affects the military
senator junior senator from New York she
came out and she said well Bill Clinton
really should have been you know
basically resigned you know Christians
come lately on Bill Clinton he was
accused of raping Juanita Broderick and
all being Paula Jones Kathleen Willey
the list goes on but now Democrats are
kind of deciding to kick the Clintons to
the curb do you find that to be credible
political what is it well without
relitigated all that the question is
what are we going to do now and we've
already passed a measure requiring
mandatory training before the end of the
year there's high likelihood we're going
to pass either another Senate rule or
legislation to outline the best way to
handle these kind of cases in the future
under any circumstances whatever is
passed any member of Congress ought to
be personally liable personally liable
for any case that he or she loses are
you in favor of unmasking the names of
those and any type of settlement group
over in the house retroactive law well
there's there's a whole bunch of people
whose names are unknown even apparently
to the congressman who is in charge of
the committee that's supposed to be over
Solara I think my attitude about this I
want to wait to see what the women of
the Senate recommend on
any other issues we're talking about so
so it could be possible that well wait
you see what the women of the Senate
recommend on that issue
why just the women of the Senate I mean
listen everybody that they're in a very
good position take the lead some men are
involved as well on both sides